what was the first that you knew that he
had been involved in the past and screen
attack when the police arrived we were
sitting watching darts and it was only
when my house phone rang and I was so
into this interested in this particular
game I picked up the phone went hello
and I said this is the police you are
surrounded by armed police put
everything down and get out now and I
looked up to eyes at the window and
mouth and the gun and that was the first
we knew wasn't until I got outside and I
said to the police officer are you
trying to tell me armored has done
something and he went yes
and I went walk and he said the bombing
and I just I was dumbstruck I just
couldn't believe it because I would not
have expected anything because he was
such a good lad and we were told to come
go he'll come he'll drop what you're
doing come out now I went to the front
door and the policeman there since all
right take your time don't rush what was
your reaction when you realize that all
of this was you still take it hard be
good to believe that he could have done
such a thing because he was such a good
boy whenever we went shopping if he was
in he saw that cut my car pull up he was
out there straightaway unloading the car
and I wait no no no no you go in I bring
this you mustn't touch to his respectful
and well yeah this is why this is why I
thought he was such a shock penny and
Ron Jones were awarded an MBE for their
services to children they've taken in
269 youngsters over 40 years were you
known to social services as a couple who
could pretty much deal with any child
from any buffer so yes yeah and we've
always tried to do
our best and when kids come to live in
my house they may be somebody else's
child but while they're in there my
house they are my responsibility they
are my children and I always refer to
them as my kids so I met Hassan was
brought here by social services and what
was your reaction the first time that
you met him he's a quiet quiet lad he
didn't have a lot to say you could see
it got a lot of problems very quiet
used to walk with his head bowed down
unless you spoke to him he told us that
he lived in Baghdad and that his mum had
been killed when the troops were out
there looking for Saddam Hussein towards
the end of that his mum was killed and
that his dad had been blown up by Isis
in his taxi as he was approaching the
taxi and did he talk about the West and
Western involvement with Iraq no he did
about my delusion I mean when we came up
to Christmas the first Christmas we came
to within there I said to him I know
you're Muslim and you don't do Christmas
but do you mind if we put a few
Christmas decorations up and his
attitude was have come to live in your
country you're a Christian country
you're a Christian family and I will go
along with it so he was a photography
student who seemed mild-mannered to you
yeah you well at college yes what went
wrong don't know I really don't know we
had a wedding anniversary just before
this happened and I had a birthday and
he told me I was his English mum yeah as
a lot of the kids do and he sent us
cards do you just want to read that card
answers because if that was your
birthday card from our Mert wasn't it
wishing you a day filled with happy
memories happy birthday to one of the
nicest personalities may God bless you
Ahmed how do you feel when you
read that birthday card now Feliz has
let me down he's betrayed me all I've
wanted to do is care for these children
make sure they get a good life and I put
them on the right track who or what do
you think
radicalized armored I don't know down
the garden and he's been walking up and
down the garden at the bottom look you
seem to be getting quite irritated at
what times I thought well he seems you
know how give me with somebody or
they've said something years on them
what he's come back I'm said to him
everything all right over it he'd say
yep fine I said oh yeah you looked a bit
annoyed when he was on the phone you
sure everything's all right if you want
to talk about anything what we're here
for
so he'd become more agitated in the
weeks before yeah I had had to speak to
him several times about phone calls two
o'clock in the morning because I'm a
light sleeper so I would hear him
talking on the phone what language did
you talking on the phone
Arabic and he used to say to me it's my
brother it's my uncle and I support they
need to phone before I go to bed this
was Ahmed's room his possessions were
taken away by the police penny and Ron
say the bedroom door had to be replaced
by the council after Ahmed head-butted
and broke it him about it and you say
that there was another young foster boy
who stayed here yeah why did the other
foster child bin yam move out because he
had said that all Muslims
brainwashed and I said well what
happened you say all Muslims well he has
the rest of them perhaps not and who who
was the other foster child talking about
our mid I don't know what gave him that
impression do you feel in any way that
there should have been more checks on
you can't have any more checks because
they've come in not from a refugee
center if they did come in for a refugee
center yes they've come in with their
papers from the refugee center so you
can check on their papers but when
they've come in on the back of a lorry
there are no checks you just have to
take it at face value he was in the camp
at Calais for a long time managed to get
himself in the truck got himself over
and as so many of them do get to Cobham
services then they picked up by the
police then social services get involved
because they're underage and he'd had
three places before he came to me and
the last place before he came to me he
was living in a student accommodation
all on his own and he couldn't cope so
looking back now how do you feel about
about fostering him and would you still
foster oh yes your foster mm-hm
just because you've got one that's done
something wrong there's still somebody
out there that needs your lovin and care
and that needs to be looked after do you
feel angry with him for bringing trouble
to your door when you've had forty years
of being kind to the once angry I'm
really disappointed that he has done
this and that he's put everybody else at
risk that's what I'm angry about but
there must have been a reason for it but
I can't say what that is I haven't had
any contact with our maid because to me
if I contact him I'm condoning what has
happened and I cannot condone what has
happened I'm sorry when you saw that
there had been this attempt to make a
bucket bomb and a number of people have
been injured but that the general view
was
could have been much much worse how did
you feel about that once I knew it was
armored I was horrified I would have
hate I'm so glad that he didn't do it
right
I'm sorry really really sorry that
people got hurt and I feel terribly
sorry for the ladies that were burnt
their legs and that were burned and I'm
I would have been distraught if people
had been killed
knowing that that had come from my house
very disappointed about it but I am
thankful that he didn't do the job
properly because I don't think I could
have lived if it had gone Oliva any
further and um well it should have done